King Robert still lived and Lord Eddard
Stark had just survived an ambush by
Jaime Lannister in King's Landing
we were the king's men charged by the
Kings hand to bring the King's justice
to the false Knight Gregor Clegane who
was raping and murdering the Kings
subjects in the Riverlands to be honest
I cared more about the King's sellers
but I joined Lord beric for the
adventure and maybe a grateful milkmaid
or two a say Gregor isn't called the
mountain because of his subtlety yet he
took us by surprise at the mummer's Ford
he'd hidden his men on both banks and as
we crossed he fell upon us from the
front and rear I saw a single blow from
his sword take a man's arm off and kill
the horse beneath him many of us though
were simply written down and drowned the
survivors spotted my damn red cloak and
rallied around me and we cut her way
free a hundred men we'd been that
morning by dark only 40 were left and
Lord beric looked to make us 39 before
morning I drew a foot of Lance from his
chest and poured boiling wine into the
hole and left but I knew there was no
hope when his light failed I shut his
eyes placed my hands on his cold chest
and mumbled a half-remembered blessing
over his body because he was my
commander and my friend and I didn't
know what else to do
then I felt his heart thud beneath his
breast his body shuddered as the fire of
life rekindled inside him I used to joke
that I became a red priest because the
robes hid the wine stains but the wine
itself hid an unbelieving heart when
beric's eyes opened so did mine I fell
to my knees and praised the one true God
and begged forgiveness for my ways I
don't know if the Lord heard me but when
Dawn came barek was still alive and
stronger than he'd been he told us that
our war hadn't ended at the mummer's
forward but begun and that every fallen
brother would be avenged
we were so few though that all we could
do was Harry the Lannisters rear luckily
all they could do was kill barek a
Lannister mace shattered his Helmand
skull a new snapped his neck after he
surrendered himself to save a beekeeper
and his wife the mountains dirt pierced
his eye through his visor after each
time I stood over his corpse and prayed
to the Lord and the Lord brought him
back then we heard that Robert was dead
and Lord Eddard - we'd been sent by the
Kings hand to deal with outlaws but now
we were the outlaws and Lord Tywin was
the hand of the king some wanted to
yield but Barrick wouldn't hear of it we
were still Kings men he said and these
were the Kings people the Lions were
savaging if we could not fight for
Robert we would fight for them until
every man of us was dead we'd lost the
Kings banner at the mummer's Ford but
then the countryside was awash with
sigils and armies anyway we became the
Brotherhood without banners
berrak led us in battle and I led us in
prayer and the Lord of Light led us in
everything
when the heralds proclaimed the end of
the war of the five kings none of us
thought of yielding our war wasn't over
the generals had gone home but the
soldiers stayed either they had no homes
to return to or they'd gotten a taste
for other people's the Brotherhood was
the people's only defense we became the
brothers of murdered siblings husbands
of murdered wives and fathers of
murdered children led by a murdered man
once we sought to bring the King's
justice to the realm now we bring the
lords or at least we try